hi everyone it's Jerry I have another
chess composition I'd like to share with
you
this is video 26 in the playlist cool
chess puzzles
it's been a while since I added to it in
each of these type of videos I highlight
one puzzle or composition this one here
is a composition by Henry rink a French
chess study composer who's considered
one of the most important early figures
in this field
it was published in 1928
in the Swiss Daily newspaper bossler
naricton
as per usual with chess compositions
it's white to move
and I'd like to encourage you to pause
the video and spend some time as much
time as you need in trying to work this
one out these are excellent exercises
for your Game Plus
you're going to want to be able to share
in the comments that you got it right
right
okay again feel free to pause the video
and when you return of course share the
solution
okay now for the solution
before I add before I point out the
first move note the king and queen
positions they're not on the same rank
but whenever this scenario is nearby
whenever the king and queen are on
adjacent ranks nearby there can be pins
there can be skewers in this case
we'll be making use of a skewer
okay especially with this guy still
around the one who operates on files and
ranks the first move
Knight F6 check
let's say the king does not want to be
on the same rank as the queen
it goes to F4 now in comes Rook H4 check
King G5 and you see what the Knight is
doing from F6
it's supporting The Rook move to H5
we could go here and if King takes
Knight
boom we just won the queen wasn't that
beautiful
white wins
hang on
that's not the end of the story
because the king could go to F4
and now this isn't just a queen this is
a poison
Queen
Rook takes Queen is now stalemate
the king is not in check
and there are no legal moves
that is the definition of stalemate
so we must try something else
what is that Knight D5 check
if Queen takes Knight Rook takes Queen
this is not stalemate white wins this
position because there is one
a legal move white will go on to win
black can try something else though
King E4 the only other try
now in comes Knight's C3 check
if Queen takes Knight Pawn takes Queen
not stalemate
there's King F4 white would win
suppose instead of Queen takes Knight
the king returns to F4
now we get to take the queen right
no
another case
of stalemate the queen in this position
is also
poison
we must try something else Knight E2
check
forcing King E4 and finally we can take
the queen
no we can't it is stalemate
again we must try something else Knight
G3 check and only after King F4 now
we're finally ready to take the queen
right no
another case of stalemate however
we have a different move we could play
here
the final key move in this position is
to make use of this intersection Square
on F5
giving check which now forces
Queen takes Rook
Knight takes Queen this is not stalemate
white will go on to win from this
position
what'd you think of this one I really
liked this Knight traveling to F6 D5 C3
E2 G3 and finally supporting
a rook moved to F5 forcing
Queen takes Knight resulting in a
non-stalemate position finally
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and yeah maybe
found it a little bit fun
that's all for now take care bye
foreign